i think my most painful memory is
actually also my
earliest memory so this is this is my
earliest memory of my life
yeah so i was i think i was about three
years old
and it's it's obviously very vivid but
it's given me a phobia of bees
okay okay to give you an idea about
where i'm going with this story
so here's so here's like my very
earliest memory i remember i was in my
parents restaurant
and i see this like thing just like
buzzing around it was it was like this
black dot just like buzzing around
and um although i remember that all i
remember thinking was i want to bat the
[ __ ] out of this thing
as the three-year-old kid i'm just like
because
it's it's like it's like moving faster
and i i've never seen a bee before so
i'm just like i'm going to bat the [ __ ]
out of this that's like some cat brain
right
yeah right it's like the thing is moving
which literally cat brain
and then all i remember was i tried
batting it and i remember it moving in a
circular motion
closing in on my eye okay oh my god like
it was like this i remember it
and then the next thing i the next thing
i feel is just this
sharp pain on my [ __ ] eye
it is it is like it it scarred me for
life
this pain i still remember to this day
and this is why i have a phobia of bees
because
that that [ __ ] was so painful and so i
run to my mum and she licks my eyes and
i will never forget my mom's face
just like pure shock just like oh [ __ ]
because
the stinger was still in my eyeball so
the whole time the bee had stung me on
my eyeball like
it wasn't like bro yeah yeah exactly and
we had to go to the doctor
we had to go to the doctor because they
had to like tweeze out the stinger
from my eyes how did you not go blind
from that i i i
i i've gone deep enough right yeah yeah
yeah it must not have gone deep enough
and i think it was long
on like the whites of my eye as well
so i probably just narrowly escaped
blindness from that [ __ ] bee
and yeah ever since then i learned an
important lesson
don't [ __ ] with bees don't [ __ ] with any
wildlife
obviously that's that's the advice i
always give to people who like want to
go to australia right it's like
how do all these australians avoid all
of these like poisonous snakes and
spiders
don't [ __ ] with them and they won't [ __ ]
with you like if you go over to like a
poisonous snake and start poking it
yeah you're gonna get [ __ ] bitten
don't do that and they won't bite you
yeah it's really easy
most animals don't want to attack you no
yeah it's it's a
it's a defense mechanism right like
don't [ __ ] with them and they won't [ __ ]
with you really simple